KAYLIN: Woo!
DARIUS: OK, I'm
Darius [INAUDIBLE]----
KAYLIN: And I'm Kaylin.
DARIUS: --and our project
was kind of a a mini-RPG,
I guess, Escape From the Zoo.
Right here's like
an opening cutscene.
So there's these
cute little animals,
and they're going to
try and escape the zoo.
KAYLIN: Yeah.
The premise of our
idea was that we
wanted to have different
animals that you could control
that each had different ways
of moving with the Kinect,
and we wanted the ways of
moving to kind of, I guess,
"connect" with the ways that
the animals themselves move.
So we have the
gecko and the frog,
who move very differently.
The penguin and the rhino.
So we have four different
types of controls that
correspond with each animal.
DARIUS: So the
goal of the game--
it's about to pop up on this
view, it's going to be great.
I never expected that.
Oh, look, there's keys
the zookeeper just
hapened to put down.
So each space is in
a small little zoo.
The keys are just
colored cubes and they
unlock the respective
color doors,
and so you have to use
each animal's gimmick
or special power to get
each of the four keys,
and then you can escape the zoo.
So there's like a
frog and everything.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DARIUS: And this is
like the backstory.
KAYLIN: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So this is
like in Grand Theft Auto.
DARIUS: Yeah, so cutscenes were
really interesting to make.
I couldn't really
quite figure it out.
We had all these image
files, and so it ended up
being a raw image with like
25 images attached to it
and then a script that was
like, every set amount of time,
switch to the next
image, and it's
like a giant long piece
of code because it's
like, if time is greater
than 50, do Image 5.
OK, we're in the game.
I'm already moving
around some penguins.
So, the controls
that are universal
is if I stick my left hand
up, I'm going to turn left.
AUDIENCE (IN DISBELIEF): No!
If I use my right hand,
I'm gonna turn right.
So now, a penguin's
move of walking
is knocking things over!
But, it's actually gonna be
a little slow and gimmicky.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER].
DARIUS: So, originally
the idea for the penguin
was to kind of go like this--
KAYLIN: It still works!
DARIUS: It actually
still kind of works,
which is great because that way
you can kind of like a penguin,
right?
However, it kind of got hard
because the shoulders are
really close to each
other, so in the code
it would be like,
if one shoulder is
in front of the other, and
because they were close,
we switched it to the hands.
So if you can see, I'm
very loose with my hands
just because it helps
with the [INAUDIBLE]..
So, you saw that
there's four animals.
So a part of this is going to
be able to switch the animals.
If I could please
switch to a frog--
KAYLIN: You're now a frog.
DARIUS: I'm now a frog.
Same general controls
with the left and right.
The frog's special
ability is jumping,
which we wanted it to be
jump, but the code for that
was a little bit harder
than I able to do
because it would have to
take the average of your head
position.
And then whenever you
had an outlier, you jump.
So that was a
little bit too much.
So the frog is kind of
like a crawling motion
where one hand's put
in front of the other.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[CHUCKLING]
AUDIENCE: What is
that [INAUDIBLE]??
KAYLIN: So--
DARIUS: Yeah, doing--
KAYLIN: Yeah, we--
DARIUS: --assets.
KAYLIN: So I built
this entire world.
And we also used
sort of terraforming.
One thing I really
wanted, I wanted the zoo
to be really crappy, like you
need to feel like the animals
like you want to
get out of here.
So I found the worst
clip art I could possibly
find of each animal.
[LAUGHTER]
And if you notice, the
"Welcome to the Zoo"
sign is in Comic Sans.
[LAUGHTER]
All of these models,
as well, are--
we found them for
between $5 to $10 each
on the Unity Asset Store.
And they came fully animated.
There's actually a lot of
animations we didn't use,
like the frog and the
penguin can eat things.
Yeah, just make sure he
doesn't jump out of the--
he can't escape yet.
DARIUS: Yeah, the game
relies on a lot of the things
the player shouldn't do,
just on basic morals.
So these fences currently
don't do anything.
They're not collisions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] them?
DARIUS: Yeah, I didn't get
into the [INAUDIBLE] on them.
There's a little bit
of find about here
that just happens with
models and not-flat surfaces.
KAYLIN: You can
also see one thing
we didn't fix is that
the horse still runs,
like the horse has
like a controller
attached to him that makes
him run, but he runs in place.
So whenever you move,
the horse moves.
I like to think it's
because he secretly
wants to leave with you, but
he's not brave enough to do it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: What's the shadow?
Yeah.
KAYLIN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The grass growing.
KAYLIN: Yeah, this is grass.
There's a lot of grass,
so it loads slowly.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So extremely [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so--
KAYLIN: It's a pretty
big world, actually.
Do you want to switch?
DARIUS: You mean-- oh, I
can keep going for a bit.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going through it.
It's so--
KAYLIN: The penguin is
probably the slowest.
DARIUS: Let's talk about-- how
about this motion right here?
It's pretty fun.
So we knew we wanted
a switching motion,
but logically, we
didn't want the player
to be able to just do this and
then like continue going on--
KAYLIN: Forever.
DARIUS: --forever.
So there has to be
a check where if you
move using left hand
instead of right once,
switch the check to left,
and then you can't get back
into that piece of code.
But if it's in a
update function,
and that means that
it ran every frame.
So it was running every
frame, but you could only
go left or right one frame.
So then you're moving
one frame at a time,
which was hilariously slow.
So the solution to that was to--
KAYLIN: Is it the
invisible wall here?
DARIUS: Yes.
I'm going to show that off.
So the penguin's
special ability is
going to be able to
slide down things.
So to keep other animals
from using that ability,
there's a nice little
invisible wall.
So, I'm going to switch
it back to penguin.
And durdle my way away.
[CLUNK]
Useless.
Oops.
The penguin does have
a sliding animation,
but I didn't get to it.
Can I go back in frog?
I want to try and jump.
See if I can shortcut
my way through this.
KAYLIN: Oh.
DARIUS: Oh, no, OK.
That's unfortunate.
So, yeah--
[LAUGHTER]
There was a counter that
counted how many frames
you're allowed to stick one
hand in front of the other.
And 30 worked pretty well.
It was like-- it
felt kind of natural
with like a pattern
that you would use
or a time that you
would use to swim.
Let's see.
Other things-- switching between
the animals was interesting.
I originally tried attaching
them all to a single player
and then having them
move the player object,
so that way it moved
all four of the models
whether or not they were
invisible at the same time.
But that kind of caused a
perpetual motion thing where
one animal would move
the player object,
but then because it was
attached to the player object,
the player object
would move the animal.
So like, you would hit the
game, and suddenly, the penguin
starts waltzing off
the playing field.
I think I'm on flat ground.
Can I switch to rhino, please?
So rhino's cool.
Didn't come with a collider,
so it's just kind of a box.
But rhino's way to move
is to charge forward.
[LAUGHTER]
It's kind of fun because you
kind of go like airplane mode.
So now I'm in the gecko zone.
Can I please be gecko?
Gecko's ability is
to climb up walls.
However, due to
time constraints,
instead of climbing
up walls, we're
going to use some magic
and just teleport.
[LAUGHTER]
Good enough.
He's going to get his key.
AUDIENCE: Wait, what is that?
DARIUS: So, would you
like to talk about NPCs?
KAYLIN: Yes.
So we're going to go visit
some of the NPCs now.
There are interacts
that you engage
with by hitting a little
invisible collider box.
There's a gorilla and a
horse, neither of whom
want to escape with you.
The gorilla's in that
sad-looking cage.
And the horse is
standing behind him.
And each interact is
specific to the animals.
So we're going to interact
with gorilla as rhino.
DARIUS: [? Hup ?] [? feed. ?]
[CHUCKLING]
I need a little break,
so this is fine.
KAYLIN: Yeah.
[LAUGHS] It's good exercise.
Oh no, he became the horse.
DARIUS: Oh, why did
the horse get there?
[LAUGHTER]
That's actually a good question.
I don't know why the horse
is behind the gorilla.
KAYLIN: It could
actually be the image.
Weird.
We had to make a
Harambe reference.
I mean, it's a gorilla in a zoo.
DARIUS: Yeah.
KAYLIN: What are we going to do?
DARIUS: Another interesting--
talk about cutscenes.
Cutscenes were fun.
KAYLIN: Oh, it automatically
goes to the horse.
DARIUS: That's unfortunate.
KAYLIN: Well, it's OK.
DARIUS: So this is like the
interaction with the horse.
KAYLIN: But it only did
part of the horse cutscene.
Maybe the images were just
put there by accident.
Whatever.
Anyways, so this is the horse.
Yeah, so as we'll find out in a
minute, we're going to leave--
oh.
DARIUS: Oh.
KAYLIN: Wow.
DARIUS: [INAUDIBLE]
A little shortcut.
KAYLIN: Oh, it must have
still been picking you up.
DARIUS: Yeah, it
was still moving.
I guess I forgot
to turn off input.
That's great.
KAYLIN: Oh, well.
So we're going to
go interact with--
DARIUS: Oh, that's why
it's turning the horse.
KAYLIN: Sure, we'll
switch with penguin.
Oh, that's why.
Yeah.
So now we'll go interact.
[LAUGHTER]
Shh.
DARIUS: Frog is pretty good.
Can I have frog?
KAYLIN: OK, we'll have frog.
There we go.
DARIUS: So interesting
things, it's like,
ooh, I think I triggered this.
When I was testing,
to get around,
I had to choose different
animals to get around.
So frog was convenient because
of the jumping was pretty fast.
The rhino's the fastest,
but because the rhino hitbox
is literally a box,
some weird things
happened where they
would hit a log
and then start flying
off into space,
or like flip over and
tumble and crazy things.
So it wasn't really
the safe route
to get to places, but if I was
feeling angry and ambitious--
ooh, weird.
Tilted.
I would like to go to rhino
and like I have fun pretending
to be like an airplane.
KAYLIN: It's called
a Dutch angle.
It's purposeful.
[CHUCKLING]
DARIUS: This is the last key.
We're almost there.
KAYLIN: Hold up.
Should I switch?
DARIUS: Not yet.
I need to line up.
KAYLIN: Is frog
faster than gecko?
DARIUS: It's
because of the jump.
AUDIENCE: Showing you over here.
DARIUS: OK.
Oop, oop, oop.
Rhino?
KAYLIN: OK.
DARIUS: So the rhino's
special ability
is being able to
break down boxes.
[ROAR] And then hit the key.
[INAUDIBLE]
However, it's a very tight
corridor, so the rhino
itself can't really
turn to get out.
KAYLIN: Oh, no.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Teamwork.
KAYLIN: Yeah.
This sort of-- another
part of the premise--
DARIUS: Oh, well, no.
KAYLIN: --was that
we wanted to make--
we wanted to make the
characters be animals
that nobody would miss if they
left the zoo, except for rhino,
who everybody would miss.
So rhino needs a lot of help.
[CHUCKLING]
DARIUS: There's always a reason.
KAYLIN: That's the plot reason.
DARIUS: So if you
noticed at the beginning,
there were doors near
the entrance here.
They're all gone.
You know, the colored keys got
rid of their respective colored
doors.
And there's a short
ending cutscene.
So I'm going to
make it to the end.
Welcome to the zoo.
Goodbye.
Freedom!
KAYLIN: Yay.
DARIUS: Ahh!
AUDIENCE: Yay.
[CHUCKLING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Are
there any questions?
It was a pretty thorough
talk through the whole thing.
DARIUS: We had a lot of time.
KAYLIN: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Any questions?
All right, awesome.
Very cool.